triangle abc undergoes the translation
and we show in our we're using the
notation capital t for it and then we
tell us we see what the trans what the
translation has to be we're going to
move we're going to move it's kind of
small i hope you can see it on your
video screen we're going to move
positive 8 every point here is going to
move positive 8 in the x direction it's
x coordinate is going to increase by 8
and or the corresponding point in the
image is x coordinate is going to
increase by 8 and the corresponding
point in the image's y coordinate is
going to decrease by one so let's do
that and i'll focus on the vertices
whoops let me drag that to the trash i
didn't mean to do that
i'm going to focus on the i'm going to
focus on the vertices
because that's well that's this is the
easiest thing for for my brain to work
with so and actually this is what the
tool expects as well so the point b is
going to move 8 to the right or its
corresponding point in the image is
going to have an x coordinate 8 larger
so right now the x coordinate is
negative 4. if you added 8 to that it
would be positive 4
and its y coordinate is going to be 1
lower right now point b's y coordinate
is 8 one lower than that is 7.
so in the image the corresponding point
in the image would be right over there
and you see we moved 8 to the right and
1 down
let's do that with point c
it's at x equals negative seven if you
move eight to the right if you increase
your x coordinate by eight you're going
to move to x equals one
and then if you change your y coordinate
by negative one you're gonna move down
one then you're gonna get to that point
right over there
now let's do it with point
point a
so point a is x coordinate is negative
one if you add eight to it it's going to
be positive seven
and its current y coordinate is two if
you take one away from it you're going
to get to a y coordinate of 1.
and so there
there you have it let's see how do i
connect how do i connect these two oh
there you go and we can check our answer
and we got it right we have performed
the translation